vamos a practicar reescribiendo
integrales definidas como el límite de
una suma de riman digamos que tenemos la
integral definida que va de p2p de
coseno de x de x lo que quiero hacer es
reescribir esto como el límite cuando n
tiende a infinito de una suma de riman
ponemos nuestra notación sigma que va
desde igual a uno hasta n lo movemos un
poco para que se vea bien vamos a
escribir lo que sucede aquí para darnos
una idea de lo que tenemos que escribir
dentro de la notación sigma aquí tenemos
que acá tenemos tres pi entre dos y aquí
tenemos dos pi como luce la gráfica de
coseno de x el coseno depp y es menos 1
que ponemos aquí y el coseno de 2 pi es
igual a 1 que ponemos acá por lo que la
gráfica va a verse más o menos así
aunque es algo que estoy dibujando a
mano así que no me va a quedar muy
exacto que digamos pero ustedes ya han
visto la gráfica de un coseno con
anterioridad
integral definida representa el área que
va desde pi hasta 2 pi entre la curva y
el eje x seguro ya se dieron cuenta de
que esta parte de la integral definida
va a ser negativa y esta otra parte de
la integral definida va a ser positiva
por lo que se cancelarán mutuamente así
que todo esto será igual a 0 en este
caso pero el propósito de este vídeo es
reescribir esto como el límite cuando n
tiende a infinito de una suma de riman
para obtener la suma de riman lo que
tenemos que hacer es descomponer esto en
n rectángulos vamos a dibujarlos y vamos
a escribir la suma de herriman en donde
el extremo derecho de nuestro rectángulo
tiene el valor de la función en ese
punto
esto es lo que define la altura
continuamos así hasta llegar a nuestro
último rectángulo
aquí tenemos igual a 1 aquí igual a 2 y
seguimos hasta llegar ahí igual a n y si
tomamos el límite cuando n se aproxima a
infinito
el área de los rectángulos va a ser
mejor cada vez ahora pensemos en cuál
será la base de cada uno de estos
rectángulos estamos tomando el intervalo
que va de pi hasta 2 pie y vamos a
dividirlo entre n intervalos iguales de
manera que la base de cada rectángulo va
a ser 2 p - pi entre n tomamos la
diferencia entre los límites de
integración de nuestra integral y la
dividimos entre n que es igual ap / m
esto mide la base de cada uno de estos
rectángulos y cuál será la altura de
cada uno de estos rectángulos recuerden
que esta es una suma de riman por la
derecha por lo que el lado derecho de
nuestro rectángulo es el que definirá la
altura por ejemplo cuál será esta altura
de acá
este valor es igual a efe de que esto es
pi y a esto le sumamos la base del
rectángulo que es p / n así que es fdp
más pi entre n por 1
esto es esta altura de aquí cuál será
esta altura de aquí ésta es fdp nuestro
comienzo y le sumamos pi entre n y lo
multiplicamos por 2 la forma general del
extremo derecho va a ser
fd comenzamos aquí en más
estamos haciendo la suma de riman por la
derecha agregamos pi entre n por n o si
queremos ver la forma general del décimo
rectángulo cuando lo sumamos todos en
este caso la altura será coseno de pi
más para el décimo rectángulo sumamos pi
entre n iv veces esta es la altura de
cada uno de nuestros rectángulos cuál es
la base está ya la habíamos encontrado
espí entre n seamos cuidadosos con la
anotación para hacer que esto aplique a
toda la expresión y ya tenemos lo que
nos piden le expresamos esta integral
definida como el límite de una suma de
riman por la derecha